pour en parler nous sommes avec mateo
gil alberti rédacteur en chef de putsch
médias bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec
nous est ce que cette démission de logis
royaux di maio du parti qu'il présidait
jusqu'à ce que c'est une surprise pour
vous non c'est pas notre surprise parce
que depuis que le mouvement 5 étoiles
s'est allié au parti démocrate en
septembre quand il a formé le deuxième
gouvernement comptait guidé par giuseppe
compter en fait on a trouvé tout de
suite que sa position allait s'affaiblir
un petit à petit et donc c'était un peu
naturel surtout parce que ce qu'ont
reproché à luigi di maio depuis son
parti même c'était déconcentré trop de
pouvoir déjà pour choisir les candidats
dans les différentes élections qui ont
été toutes remportées par la ligue du
nord depuis septembre c'est à dire les
élections régionales par exemple en
ombrie et puis donc ces candidats a
choisi par luigi di maio ont perdu donc
cette chose a affaibli sa leadership à
l'intérieur du parti et en plus c'est
bien qu'avant dans le gouvernement
comptait 1
ils étaient ils avaient la double
casquette de ministre du travail et de
ministres aussi de vice président du
conseil des ministres là il était aussi
ministre des affaires étrangères dans le
deuxième gouvernement comptait donc il
garde cette position
mais cette fonction mais il a quitté le
guide du mouvement 5 étoiles c'est peut
être aussi un signe de
guerre à l'intérieur de mouvement qui va
éclater surtout si les élections de ce
prochain dix marches n'essaieront pas
bonne pour ce mouvement des élections
régionales qui en emilie romagne et en
calabre s'annonce très difficile pour le
mouvement 5 étoiles dans ce contexte
qu'est ce qui se joue à laon réellement
en arrière-plan avec cette démission
effectivement il a voulu sortir du monde
hier de la scène politique de son parti
quelques minutes avant une éventuelle
défaite parce que si on regarde les
derniers sondages disponibles parce que
la loi interdit les les sondages après
le 10 janvier
on voit que le mouvement 5 étoiles en
emilie romagne qui est celle plus plus
attendu comme un région
et ça test au sens que 6% des intentions
de vote
naturellement il ya beaucoup d'indécis
et donc c'est difficile d'avoir une idée
claire de ce qui va se passer mais alors
la grande look plus de serra entre la
ligue de matteo salvini et le parti
démocrate qui est qui a administré cette
région jusqu'à ce moment et qu'il ya une
région historiquement rouge de comme
mondial italien coach est ancré à gauche
et il a s et on annonce en tête à tête
entre les deux entre les deux candidats
est l'enjeu est de taille puisqu'une
victoire de l'extrême droite dans cette
région pourrait provoquer des élections
législatives anticipées c'est ce que
redoute le gouvernement oui tout à fait
parce qu'en fait comme je disais tout à
l'heure les élections régionales qui ont
eu lieu ces derniers mois ont été toutes
remportées par la ligue ou en tout cas
parler centre droit parce que la ligue
est allié aussi à la force et à l'ire de
silvio berlusconi affronter l'italienne
giorgia meloni
donc c'est un peu comme si les italiens
avaient voté en morceaux et donc ils ont
changé le la scène politique là la clé
10 ont montré de changer leur confiance
vis-à-vis des
de ceux qui gouvernent le pays
typiquement le mouvement 5 étoiles et
part est passée de
de 30% d'intentions de vote à plus ou
moins 15 % au niveau national donc on
voit bien que les rapports de force ont
changé radicalement
didier mayau reste membre à part entière
du gouvernement
mais quel effet ce que sa démission peut
avoir sur l'exécutif italien est ce que
nous vous parce qu'on rappelle ans le
mouvement 5 étoiles est l'un des deux
piliers de ce gouvernement
quel effet nationale on n'a plus un
leader de parti à l'intérieur de
gouvernement donc le parti devra décider
différemment sur beaucoup de choix
politiques qui seront adoptées par le
gouvernement donc
ça affaiblit encore plus cet executive
que déjà à un très faible parce que dans
le parlement en particulier dans la
chambre haute du sénat et il a un nombre
de parlementaires très limité et de plus
un peu comme il s'est passé en france
avec le républicain marche le mouvement
5 étoiles continue à perdre de
parlementaires qui sort qu'ils
démissionnent du groupe du moment cinq
étoiles aussi bien à la chambre des
députés et au sénat et donc ils
affaiblissent encore plus la position de
ce gouvernement et la démission alors de
leur président à la tête du mouvement 5
étoiles c'est un nouveau coup dur c'est
le coup de grâce pour nous en tant
qu'étoile comment est ce que vous voyez
les choses il lui dieu du meilleur
annoncé aussi voilà qui restera à
disposition du parti mais ce qu'on pense
aussi c'est qu'il pourrait céder
certains observateurs un italien
il pourrait fonder un autre artiste
notamment dans les régions du sud où il
a une conduire une certaine suivi et il
pourrait donc
drainer des votes au mouvement 5 étoiles
merci beaucoup pour votre regard matteo
jose alberti je rappelle que cette fin
le rédacteur en chef de putsch médias